hasn't just won it once he's won it
twice seeking to become a three-time
winner of this event fabi this opening
we were saying
you're just leaving the guy alone
making some some moves getting pieces
developed
what was your plan as you're known as a
big theoretician but so is sam
yeah i i mean i was winging it um i
don't know if he was but i assume he
didn't have so much familiarity with the
position because he was also thinking
early on uh i think we were both trying
to figure out
uh the subtleties of it because it's a
very complicated line um
and i'm not sure if we
if we managed um but i was quite happy
at least with the result of the opening
i mean this this is what i was aiming
for i just wanted
um a more or less equal position where
the game is going to
take a long time
yeah so if you can bring this up on your
board absolutely yeah we're at move 11
when fabi played c3 and there's a
critical moment after e5
bishop to h2
that here
uh he could actually instead of playing
queen e7 take on d4 and go for a queen
a5 check threat what was your plan for
this well actually i missed it when i i
went for this um because i wanted to
play knight d4 and id4 queen d4
knight g4 is i think the only logical
move
queen d6 and missed bishop c3
that would have been a cold shower well
yeah i hope hopefully i would have
figured out in time and i assume that
that white has uh
more than one way to equalize for
example queen c4 should equalize um
but yeah i i wouldn't uh
wouldn't have an advantage that's that's
for sure
he did play otherwise he played queen to
e7 and that transformation of the
structure with his pawn on e4 pawn on d5
seemed to favor you all the way
yeah i was i was happy to get this
because
um
he doesn't really have any
plans you know he wants to get f5 but
but that once he his knight leaves f6
i'll get f3 um the only thing which took
me a while to decide on was to play
knight d2 or knight e1 um but i i
decided that the tempo was worth getting
the knight to
a square where it defends the e3 knight
with the knight on d2 then bishop h6
really
not immediately but if i ever try for f3
stuff bishop h6 will
uh will bug my knight he'll play d5
anyway and i didn't see why
what i do with this extra tempo that i
got
uh and then i i think
i mean i'm more comfortable but
it it flowed a bit too easily i think um
something went wrong for him
maybe he shouldn't have gone for this
because once
this happens somehow
it's so unpleasant i mean all my pieces
just stream into the game
and
somehow the moves all came very
naturally
um
and i was lucky of course that uh that i
had knight g4 that was
uh that was nice
uh late i'm not on this night this one
but also this one was was all right but
this is the next one that turned into a
bomb when you say you were lucky you saw
the light the line coming didn't you
when i played 95 i i saw this uh this
line
um but i didn't think that he had
anything
well not i mean he must have something
better but i didn't think he had
anything
to
um to get a normal position
because of course he can trade all the
rooks and play knight c6 or or some such
sequence but
it's just i think long-term
either losing or very close to losing
because i i have the dark square bishop
and
he has the weak and dark squares and the
weak king
um
[Music]
i mean maybe it's not objectively losing
but practically it's a nightmare
great start for you this this idea when
you play knight g4 queen g5 you saw this
line coming
was is it hard not to get excited i know
a lot of players will just be like oh
this looks good
yeah i was excited uh it was really i
mean knight g4
like this type of queen sacrifice with a
smothered mate is
uh
is so rare that it's a pleasure to get
it and uh of course first your thought
is like h5 oh i'm losing a piece but
then
um i realized that uh his king gets
completely opened up and
um
and there's really nothing to do it's
remarkably hopeless for him after queen
g5 i don't know if you know there's a
brilliancy prize of an additional five
thousand dollars
in this
tournament that was donated by brian
priester of key west florida is that
something on your mind is that going to
make you play the spicy move versus the
boring one
well i mean i hope that that this game
will suffice then
[Laughter]
also maxime i think played a really
excellent game today um i don't know for
sure but it really looked good it's not
winning the villain surprise i can tell
you that
we're not giving that one out yours mike
are you are you the judge maurice the
three of us
don't try to influence us no no i'll
give you a little cutting the air
how dare you say that how dare you
50
the dishonor he shows
60 40. we get the 60.
thank you so much for joining us great
game
really nice
but
definitely an excellent game good luck
in the rest of your tournament thanks
maurice absolutely well done